We covered a lot in this lesson.
Now you know how to send specific
hits to Google Analytics for
screen views, events, steps in
the shopping process, and timing data.
I also talked about
tracking exceptions and
crashes, as well as tracking
how users download your app.
But what if you want to send
completely different kinds of data that
the amazing engineers
at Google Analytics
hadn't thought of when they
created the dashboard and API?
Well, they're ahead of you.
They knew they couldn't anticipate
every possible use case, so
they added the ability for
you to add your own custom metadata
when you send hits to Analytics.
You'll need to configure custom metrics,
or dimensions, in the Analytics admin
dashboard and then attach the custom
data when sending the hit in your code.
I'll leave you to read about that
in the developer documentation
when you are ready to try it out.
But, now,
let's go learn about Tag Manager.